ماشا أفهم أنك كنت بالفعل
قيد الإقامة الجبرية
وتبقى في شقة صديقتك في موسكو
عندما اتصلت بك السلطات
ماذا قالوا وما الذي جعلك
تقرر أن هذا هو الوقت المناسب للمغادرة
آه
لم
أكن في الواقع تحت الإقامة الجبرية
كنت أنا كذلك  كنت أرتدي سوارًا إلكترونيًا
وكنت تحت حكم
تقييد الحرية وقبل ذلك
كنت تحت استراحة منزلية وإلى جانب هذا
السوار الإلكتروني تم اعتقالي ست
مرات واه أمضيت ست مرات أه
لمدة 15 يومًا
في السجن لذلك كنت مثل ضعف
تم القبض عليك ، أعتقد أنه تم القبض عليك
ست مرات منذ الصيف الماضي ، أعني أنه
كان هناك حكم بالسجن لمدة عامين
في عام 2012 ، لكن ست مرات تم
القبض عليك منذ الصيف الماضي ، أعني أن
هذا أمر غير عادي ، فما حدث
هذه المرة
أه هذه المرة  لقد قررت للتو أنه
تم تحديد موعد جولتي ومن المهم بالنسبة لي
أن أدلي ببيان ضد الحرب
بصوت عالٍ قدر المستطاع وأن أتحدث بصوت عالٍ قدر
المستطاع عما رأيته في روسيا.
لقد
أجريت تغييرًا بسيطًا وقررت عدم
قضاء 21 يومًا في السجن ولكن أقضيه
في استوديو البروفة في أغنيتك
إذا كان بإمكانك إخبارنا عن كيفية
خروجك قلت إن لديك سوارًا إلكترونيًا
ما الذي يتطلبه الأمر  اخرج من
البلد ، لدينا صورة لك
أنت وصديقتك لوسي مرتدين زي
سعاة توصيل الطعام ، أنت على اليسار
لوسي على اليمين
الذي تستخدمه كما أفهمه كقناع
للتهرب من الشرطة التي كانت تطارد
شقتها
كيف أتيت بهذه الفكرة
أعتقد أنها كانت فكرة رائعة
واستخدمتها
أولاً ثم
أه استخدمتها أه عندما
كان ذلك بمثابة دوري ولكن
أه الشيء هو أنني
تسللت
إلى هذا الزي الرسمي أه من الشقة التي
كنت محاطًا بالشرطة السياسية
وأيضًا كان موقفًا أكثر صعوبة بعض الشيء
لأن
جواز سفري الدولي تمت
مصادرته ، لذا
لم يكن لديك
جواز سفر روسي لم يكن لديك جواز سفر روسي لقد صادروه
أه نعم لدينا في روسيا جميع
المواطنين لديهم  اثنان سنة  الرياضات الداخلية والدولية ،
لذلك من غير الممكن
السفر مع الداخل ، كل ذلك باللغة الروسية
ولا يعني أي شيء للعالم
فقط بالنسبة لروسيا ،
لذا فقد أخذوا جواز سفري الدولي
نعم لقد ذهبت أولاً إلى بيلاروسيا
هي بيلاروسيا  آمن أعني
لأنك كنت تنتقد زعيم
بيلاروسيا البيلاروسية غير آمنة بنسبة 100٪
صدقني بيلاروس ترى
ديكتاتورية رهيبة
بنفس الجنون المهووس أه في السلطة ،
لكنها نوع من طريقة واحدة فقط تعرفها
وآه إذا كنت
كذلك  من بيلاروسيا ، كنت تحاول الوصول
إلى ليتوانيا ، من أين أنت ، من
الواضح أنهم كانوا يعرفون أنك غادرت
في تلك المرحلة أو كانوا يعرفون أنك في
مكان ما
منذ متى كنت في بيلاروسيا وأين
كنت أعني أنك لا تستطيع البقاء في فندق
أفترض
آه لا ، لم أستطع
بشكل جيد ، لقد استخدمت تجربتي المسرحية
ومساعدة أصدقائي
للبقاء في أماكن دون التسجيل
بجواز سفري ،
لذا كان عليك الوصول
إلى ليتوانيا  لاروس الحدود مع ليتوانيا
أنت ، ما كان
ذلك جيدًا لأنني نجحت
من المرة الثالثة
واستغرق الأمر ثلاث مرات
نعم ثلاث مرات ما حدث في المرة الأولى
آه
كانت المرة الأولى كابوسًا للمرة الثانية كان
جيدًا ، لقد قالوا للتو لم تكن
المرة الأولى فظيعة في
المرة الأولى  كان مثل البحث عني
في السيارة حيث كنت
أه
ساعتين أتحدث مع محقق رهيب من الكيلوجرام
وما إلى ذلك